nuevos compromisos en la cob 26 en
concreto 100 líderes de países que
representan el 85 por ciento de los
bosques del planeta han prometido 12 mil
millones de dólares en inversión pública
y 7 mil 200 en participación privada
para frenar la deforestación antes de
2030 brasil cuyo presidente había sido
criticado por la comunidad internacional
por no tomar medidas para proteger la
amazonía sostiene que bajara sus
emisiones en un 43% para 2030
son importantes para mí los ojos que son
importantes porque cubren el 60% del
territorio de mi país son fuentes de
salud y vida y hogar de las más grandes
riquezas naturales y de biodiversidad en
nuestro planeta asumimos el compromiso
de eliminar la deforestación ilegal para
2030 de smata mente de ago apeado entre
algunos países como colombia quieren
actuar cuanto antes
bernard waiting and swan history
no vamos a esperar a 2030 estamos aquí
comprometiéndonos a proteger el 30% de
nuestro territorio como área protegida
en 2022 porque debemos actuar ahora los
we más
además los países de la cumbre apostaron
por reducir las emisiones de metano el
segundo mayor gas de producción humana
que calienta el planeta después del co2
cerca de 100 naciones aseguraron que
reducirán estas emisiones en un 30% para
aunque no han definido una hoja de ruta
concreta para hacerlo juntos estamos
comprometidos a reducir colectivamente
nuestra producción de metano a 30% de
aquí a 2030 y creo que posiblemente
vayamos a superar esa meta a pesar de
las promesas de los líderes de la cob 26
los expertos siguen advirtiendo sobre la
necesidad de actuar con urgencia para
frenar la crisis climática y es que los
datos son preocupantes durante los
últimos 13 años más de 43 millones de
hectáreas de bosque en todo el mundo han
sido destruidas